[Musik]
[Applaus]
zwei beklagt ist die schönste yacht
eigentlich eine spezielle jagd haben wir
nicht jedes jahr pro jahr genug als
senioren dass ich mich kümmere das
gemüse darf
diese tiere wieder strom
ich freue mich so dass ich das für
sonntag
[Musik]
36 jahre hat dominique jäger auf diesen
moment gewartet
die möglichkeit einen kapitalen
steinbock zu erliegen
doch geschenkt bekommt er ihn nicht auf
ihn wartet eine große herausforderung
und nur wenn alles zusammenpasst wird es
der höhepunkt seines lebens als jäger
davon handelt dieser film eine woche
bevor die jagd beginnt erkundet
dominique die wahl minow im oberengadin
dieses tal könnte möglicherweise für die
jagd zugeteilt werden
für den oberhalb steiner neuland in
puncto jagd umso wichtiger ist es
herauszufinden wo sich die tiere hier
aufhalten
sie haben wir beide sind wie genial des
gastes schätzt sie
79 ich warte mal momenten muss nicht nur
im gros der sprecher man habe halt
richtig ansprechen bezeichnet in der
jägersprache die präzise beobachtung des
tiers zwischen sechs und zehn jahre alt
muss seinen steinbock sein
der abschuss eines unerlaubten teams hat
für den jäger größere konsequenzen
er muss eine busse zahlen und darf die
trophäe also die hörner nicht behalten
das alter ablesen kann man bei den
steinböcken an den hörnern
ein kurzer blick genügt aber nicht um
die sau raus zu finden
auch ohne gewähr wird gebeten steinböcke
aus nächster nähe zu beobachten ist
immer ein besonderes erlebnis
3 gleich den kopf drehen
das geht so in die schule gebracht
kurz war also allerlei von portugal
steht
da könnte man dass wir langsam langsam
wieder locker und du siehst ist transco
der adrenalinspiegel steht ein
gewaltiger eine woche muss er noch
warten dann ist es soweit
an geduld mangelt es ihm nicht von bis
zu seinem 58
lebensjahr musste dominique jäger warten
bis er jetzt bei seiner dritten
steinwild jagd endlich einen großen
steinbock ins visier nehmen darf wie
sein name verrät waren schon seine
vorfahren begnadete jäger eine
leidenschaft die sozusagen von
generation zu generation weitergegeben
worden ist
es begegnet als zu früheren radfahrer
hat wieder jagd werde ich aktiv sind zu
und der geht nicht nötig sie das mal mit
ihm ab und jagt sind neuer salz braucht
fürs wild und die und in die verwandten
auch jeder vierte partie damit kommen
das ist natürlich schon früher er also
ich meine kraxeln hinter die aktive
sagen oder so
sein jagdgebiet kennt er in- und
auswendig die täler und berge hier
oberhalb von pontresina sind ihm aber
fremd eine große herausforderung und ich
denke dass er zu recht unser kugel zum
schluss von den 6000 steinböcken gegen
graubünden heimisch sind müssen jedes
jahr um die 500 geschossen werden damit
die population im gleichgewicht bleibt
diese regulierung dürfen jedes jahr nur
eine kleine anzahl jäger übernehmen
daher auch die langen wartelisten für
jeden jäger zwei tiere soll dominique
jäger erlegen seinem kapitalen steinbock
und eine stein geist die habe zuerst
schiessen muss so schreibt es das gesetz
vor
dieser geist könnte gut sein
dominique jäger versucht nah
heranzugehen
[Musik]
wäre heute schon sagt es wäre ein guter
tag
bei der stein geist ist nicht das alter
entscheidend sondern ob sie sorgend ist
oder nicht erlegen darf man nur eine
stein geist die kein jungtier aufzieht
nicht immer ganz einfach in einer gruppe
solch eine auszumachen
mögliche kandidaten wären jedoch dabei
sowohl und doch kreist sexy und es ist
eine beruhigung des ezb dominique jäger
ist bereit für das gebiet in der wahl -
ob die tiere in einer woche noch da sind
in dieser zeit kann sich viel verändern
am ersten markttag kommt die
ernüchterung nicht die wahl wurde ihm
zugeteilt sondern die wahl lang war
[Musik]
in begleitung seines bruders john
beginnt die jagd mit der suche nach
einer passenden stein geist
dass es wieder ein neues gebiet ist das
er nicht kennt bringt ihn aber nicht aus
der ruhe
mit dem osterhofen sehen wir sicher
beruf machen
positives denken hilft gegen das
ungewisse und wird kurze zeit später
will und
23 sind geblieben
das fernrohr muss her
ein unersetzliches werkzeug für das
ansprechen
die gruppe scheint es aber eilig zu
haben wurden die jäger schon entdeckt
zügig verschwinden die tiere aus dem
blickfeld
eine gute taktik ist nun gefragt
dominique jäger entscheidet sich die
verfolgung aufzunehmen
in diesen höhen macht einem das wetter
häufig einen strich durch die rechnung
schlagartig zieht nebel auf
[Musik]
auch wenn die gruppe in schussdistanz
wäre
die tiere werden vom nebel verschluckt
und sind weg
[Musik]
doch die sonne bekommt wieder die
oberhand und mit ihr steigt auch die
chance auf erfolg
wo in der 15 aber dennoch nie ganz keine
gespräche
links und rechts und das ist nie
probiert laura schriewer
[Musik]
das gelände ist sehr offen
ich entscheide mich das ganze aus der
distanz zu beobachten um des jägers
glück nicht herauszufordern
[Musik]
ein gut platzierter schuss und das tier
ist sofort tot
während der rest der gruppe den tatort
verlässt begibt sich dominique jäger zu
seiner beute
spanische equipe micro das ist gleichsam
und die ist gut und wir können auf der
burg kloster schöner moment auch bruder
john ist mittlerweile angekommen und
begutachtet das erlegte tier als symbol
für die letzte mahlzeit vor dem tod wird
der stein geist der letzte biss gewährt
ein alter jagd braucht um respekt zu
erweisen
[Musik]
ein neuer herbsttag zeigt sich von
seiner schönsten seite
lange soll es aber nicht so bleiben
schlechtes wetter ist angesagt und
schnee in diesen höhen würde die jagd um
ein vielfaches erschweren
heute sollte es deshalb gelingen und
diesen moment miterleben wohl nach
tochter madeleine und ne viele andere
dass die familie ab und zu mit kommt ist
nichts außergewöhnliches die jagd ist
wie das wandern eine leidenschaft die
man auch gerne gemeinsam betreibt
die zwei brüder die sich in ihrer
kindheit nicht sonderlich gut verstanden
fanden mit der jagd eine gemeinsamkeit
die achtgrößte ist mit dem mikro
verschreibung tagen bin ich schon ein
komisches gefühl momentan ja
unterhalb von bislang war ist der
überblick über den talkessel am besten
und es geht nicht lange bis dominique
jäger die erste gruppe entdeckt
auch weiter oben sichten sie größere
steinböcke sie wurden allerdings von
etwas gestört und ziehen sich in die
felsen zurück schnell ist auch klar
wieso an einem schönen sonntag wie
diesen sind auch die wanderwege gut
besucht vor den wanderern sind die
steinbrück gegen sicherheit
doch auch dominique gefällt dieser
rastplatz jetzt muss nur noch ein guter
bock dabei sein
jene drei ich will ich sie also fliegen
oder so wahnsinnig in den usa schwächte
die archäologie oder windows aber mehr
interessieren und micro stellt das
eigentlich so klappen
jeder einzelne bock wird ganz genau
studiert und dann ist es soweit
dominique jäger hat seinen steinbock
außer von neun jahre hat er gezählt
200 meter muss er sich noch nähern bis
er die ideale schussdistanz hat die
familie bleibt zurück und beobachtet von
hier aus das geschehen
[Musik]
ja
zeichnet sie das sind zeichen einer
decke das können wir langsam
und das muss ich wurde in dem blatt
so kann sie wird sich bin sehr
zuversichtlich
zum bunten 807 euro ist die sinne weisz
hatte sich erst aus der nähe hat er die
gewissheit über das alter richtig
bestimmt hat auch der rest der gruppe
kann es kaum erwarten
jahrhundert
verzweiflung macht sich breit hat sich
dominique jäger verschätzt
ausgerechnet bei seiner wichtigsten
treffer her
wäre dies der fall müsste er den
steinbock abgeben
danke und du musst nicht neu sondern
zehn jahre das höchste was für ihn
erlaubt gewesen ist
und stolz ja auf jeden fall wohl ist
eine große ehre dass der dtb sie ist
nicht immer selbstverständlich ist schon
jäger ist ebenfalls überglücklich über
den erfolg seines bruders auch dass er
derjenige sein darf der das erlegte tier
ausweitet dominique jäger lehnt sich
lieber zurück und genießt jeden
augenblick dass ich freute mich des
stolzes handel von macht dieser apotheke
süßen konto
also ja nie
am schluss hat alles gepasst dominique
jäger hat die herausforderung gepackt
und seinen traum vom kapitalen steinburg
verwirklicht
[Musik]